why is letting go of bad habits so hard
and why is creating better habits
equally hard if not harder a lot of this
begins with identifying your values
first being clear on who you are now and
who you aspire to be well to close that
Gap and eat away at that dissonance you
need to know the end game the person you
aspire to be so again back to that
Clarity and then you need to backtrack
from there and identify the steps that
are going to get you there these new
stepping stones are going to be the
fabric upon which you build these new
habits until they are fully ingrained
and the way that you do that is you
identify and start with really small
doable things that you can begin doing
right away things that are just a little
bit out of your comfort zone but not too
much out and then you start knocking
them down like doing them and that
creates momentum then it's about just
continuing to keep the pressure on and
increasing the degree of difficulty of
those little doable steps as you kind of
progress